Thomas Jefferson one of America's
founding fathers came up with the first
swiveling mechanism for office chairs
decades later Charles Darwin added small
wheels called casters to his chair to
rolled around the study as he worked on
the theory of evolution
today office chairs still swivel and
roll the office chair has become a
status symbol executive versions have
kingly dimensions
they're extremely plush and have serious
lumbar support
[Music]
ing a hydraulically powered machine a
worker bends 14 gauge steel tubing to
form the bottom cushion frame
he joins the ends and welds steel bars
to the middle
the bars will support the mechanism for
adjusting the position of the seat
[Music]
he hooks s-shaped steel Springs from the
front to the back of the seat frame
sinua Springs will eventually provide a
flexible web of suspension in the seat
[Music]
he positions the rods laterally and
clips them to the springs for additional
stability and support
the office chair seat frame is now
complete
[Music]
a worker builds the chair's back frame
the frame includes a spine lumbar
support armrest attachments and other
parts
he grinds Burrs and other rough spots
from the steel
in the upholstery Department another
worker Smooths a leather hide so that it
sits evenly on the cutting table
he cuts out the patterns following
cardboard templates
as he cuts he works around the natural
flaws in the hide making calculated
decisions to minimize waste
by cutting carefully he'll be able to
get all the leather he needs for one
chair from this large hide
that's important because color and grain
can vary from hide to hide
using pieces from the same one will give
the chair a consistent look and texture
and saw the leather pattern pieces have
been accumulated another worker Cuts
foam cushioning for backing
the density of the foam in the chair
varies he uses more rigid foam for the
chair's contoured cushioning so it will
hold its shape
another worker selects softer foam for
the part of the chair that the
occupant's back will rest against
[Music]
slits into this softer back padding this
creates channels that will ultimately
become a design feature
[Music]
in chalk he draws lines onto the
corresponding leather
that match up with the slits in the foam
hooker aligns the chalk lines in the
leather with the slits
and puckers the leather as he sews the
backing to it
this forms a rip pattern in the upper
half of the chair upholstery
[Music]
is the padding flat to many of the other
pattern pieces
this particular part is a side panel for
the back of the chair
returning to the upholstery with the
ribbing now he sews contoured casings to
each side
[Music]
to complete the back of the chair
workers at a chipboard panel and encase
the structure with foam then cover it
with the leather upholstery
once the chair seat has been upholstered
an employee installs a plastic cover to
enclose the back
[Music]
sliding plate to the base
this mechanism will work in conjunction
with the plate to slide the seat forward
and backward depending on leg room needs
it also has features for adjusting the
Tilt and height of the seat
the hydraulic cylinder for adjusting the
seat height is next the cylinder also
doubles as the chair stem and it swivels
to allow the seat to rotate 360 degrees
[Music]
the aluminum base to the cylinder
snaps the casters into slots in the
aluminum base
[Music]
the back of the office chair with an
automobile style headrest
the prongs fit into the brackets in the
chair frame
finally he locks the armrests into the
frame
[Music]
this office chair is now ready to make
someone's desk job a lot more
comfortable
Vino Brew is just with the name implies
Vino meaning wine and Brew referring to
beer this hybrid beverage is part of a
fledgling Trend by some adventurous
breweries and wineries to merge their
two otherwise separate worlds of alcohol
and create a unique drink
[Music]
Vino Brew is made from Port style sweet
wine dark strong beer known as Stout
and another ingredient that's brewed
coffee this concoction is the
collaborative creation of a winery micro
Brewery and coffee producer the micro
Brewery grows some 20 different
varieties of hot plants whose flowers
contain the resins and essential oils
that give beer its bitter and aromatic
characteristics
beer making process the brewmaster fills
a tank called a mash tune with water
then ignites a burner
when the water heats to around 150
degrees Fahrenheit he pours in a blend
of different types of malts
Are cereal grains such as barley or corn
which have been soaked to kick-start
germination then once sprouted dried
with hot air to Halt germination
stirring The Malt into the hot water
activates enzymes that convert the
starches in the grain into fermentable
sugars
after an hour or so he transfers just
the liquid called wart to the boil
Kettle and gradually adds different
varieties of hops
he brings the wart to a boil to kill off
bacteria and sterilize it
next he cools the wart and transfers it
to the fermentation tank then he adds
yeast over the next 10 to 14 days the
yeast consumes the fermentable sugars in
the wart converting them into alcohol
and producing carbon dioxide gas which
creates bubbles this process transforms
the wart into beer
at the coffee company the hot coffee
beans must be cooled quickly after
coming out of the roaster so that they
don't overcook
this perforated cooling pan stirs the
beans to help dissipate the heat then a
commercial coffee grinder grinds the
beans into coarse ground coffee
to prepare coffee for the Vino brew a
worker puts grounds into a filter bag
saturates the bag with cold water then
submerges the bag in water letting the
ground soak for about 16 hours
then he pours the coffee into a large
jar
at the winery winemakers Harvest and
press the grapes add yeast and ferment
them then age the port wine for at least
two years in Oak barrels
to prepare to make Vino Brew the
winemakers test samples from different
barrels for acidity and sweetness to
help decide which wines to potentially
use
[Music]
the wine maker and the coffee maker then
experiment with amounts of those wines
and different cold brew coffees made
from various types of beans
the brewmaster also joins in measuring
out beer
[Music]
this process is as much art as science
for each batch of Vino Brew the
respective makers play with the
selection of ingredients and with the
proportions tasting and smelling the
samples to evaluate Aroma sweetness
bitterness and acidity
[Music]
what they try to create is a harmonious
blend of the three elements a new flavor
without the taste of any one element
dominating the others
[Music]
once they pin down the winning formula
they replicate it on a large scale for
production
the winery pumps the selected wine from
storage tanks into barrels for transport
to the brewery
foreign
the brewmaster pumps the required amount
of wine from those barrels into a
blending tank
he pours the required amount of cold
brewed coffee into the blending tank
then he pumps the required volume of
beer into the tank
beer makes up the largest proportion of
the recipe followed by wine then coffee
after blending the ingredients in the
tank the brewmaster pumps the Vino Brew
into a beer keg then he injects carbon
dioxide gas to add more carbonation
when you pour a glass of Eno Brew the
bubbles rise to the top producing foam
known as beer head
but while this might look and feel like
regular beer
one sip tells you that Vino Brew is
uniquely different
[Music]